já a a k há algum problema nisso foi
[Música]
vocês sabiam que existe uma ciência que
só estuda o riso banda de cientistas só
isto do riso
chama-se gelo tecnologia tem um nome
carné geologia têm dizer três vezes pelo
gênero e de acordo com a geologia isto
que acabamos de fazer rir como nós
acabamos de ver a queima 40 calorias
li é melhor do que qualquer uma dessas
dietas cada por aí e ainda segundo a
cirurgia
segundo estudos conduzidos na
universidade de stefan o riso tem
benefícios físicos mentais e sociais
fisicamente quando nos vimos nos relaxam
os músculos libertação de hormonas que
promovem a nossa auto imunidade
o riso 32 dor
o riso e dos riscos de impotência
rir é melhor do que quando teve hd e
vocês sabiam que quando nós rimos nos
exercitamos de 1284 músculos faciais é
verdade e se esse processo extinto a
polícia fica puxa justifica por si
justifica ela estica a pele e isso
retarda o processo de aparecimento de
rugas níveis oferece também mentalmente
rir descontrai alivia o estresse nos da
boa disposição e isso reduz os riscos de
depressão socialmente pessoas que vivem
juntas têm melhores relações
ri melhor o ambiente de trabalho
rio os torna mais atraentes
eu na vida real sou feio mas por que
estou aqui a sorrir ea vila de moreira
bonito
brad pitt é mas porque eu estou aqui a
falar sobre quem sou eu
eu sou humorista faz stand up comedy com
grupo improviso de 2010 quando eu me
aproximei do grupo improviso não tinha
nenhuma intenção de fazer está na comida
eu queria pedir emprestado de uma câmara
para afirmar uma peça entrada
em vez disso me mandaram trabalhar para
eles
é tempo eles ao vizinho pedir uma
chávena de açúcar que mandar lavar os
pratos
então comecei a fazer sentar comigo com
eles
a minha primeira atuação foi o
espetáculo toda a gente riu
eu falei sobre a minha experiência no
chá
eu estava na chapa como a senhora ea
filha dela pegar na bunda da menina ea
senhora como é só fazermos cada um de
vocês jovens são os mais criados no de
educação a só pegar as bundas das nossas
filhas e não pegam as nossas porque
na minha segunda atuação do shenyang a
[Música]
rio e foi assim na terceira e na quarta
e na quinta as coisas já sabiam qual era
a minha vez atuar aproveitavam a atender
o fone para cada bairro
até pra fazer lista do bolo lista de
lobo no profissional tem que parar um
cadinho e pensar do que estou fazendo é
errado porque as minhas pernas não tem
graça
aí eu me lembrei da minha primeira
atuação que eu falei sobre a minha
experiência a minha vida pessoal e eu
decidi que era isso que eu queria falar
andar a falar sobre coisas que não sei
e desde lá até aqui hoje eu já no rocha
muito nesses meus 10 anos de carreira
eu já fui em grandes palcos
gil vicente google auditório municipal
da marola minha casa barre e já divide
palco com muitos monstros da comédia não
sabe cada mario gaia o mito amb e quando
eu digo monstros não é porque eles são
muito engraçados é porque são feios
[Música]
ok o que bruno 3 bom tem uma carreira
excelente na comédia mas o que vejo nos
oferecer
é a pergunta que vocês devem estar a
pensar pois é eu devemos ensinar como se
conta uma piada mas em primeiro lugar o
que é uma piada uma piada é o meu
salário não era esposa graça uma piada é
uma frase um bom conjunto de frases que
são supostos fazer para unir o que faz
uma piada fazer lê tem muitos elementos
que podem fazer uma pedra fazer e dentre
eles a desconexa oncológica
nós ouvimos algo que não faz sentido
nós rimos empatia e já aconteceu
nós rimos e principal de todas é a
surpresa quando nós ouvimos algo que não
estávamos à espera
então eu vou aqui hoje ensinar três
estruturas três tipos de piadas primeiro
tempo
sentar para stone muito simples é
composto por duas partes na primeira
parte eu inicio a conversa e na segunda
parte eu quero com vossa lógica com
a história exemplo a mimar se casou no
mês passado
fiquei muito triste esta é acertar a
vossa lógica está a começar a funcionar
porque que ele ficou triste
ok aí vem a partir daí a minha irmã se
casou no mês passado
fiquei muito triste pelo meu cunhado vai
sofrer muito
[Música]
o segundo tipo é lista 373 também
simples nós não estávamos três coisas em
que as duas primeiras fazem sentir uma
conta mas a terceira não faz muito
sentido mas ainda assim tem relação com
as duas
eu gosto muito de bebês eles são
fofos cheiram bem e animal fazer o
terceiro tipo é a comparação
na comparação nos comparar os dois
conceitos diferentes dos conceitos que
os 21 do outro lado de um lado não são
engraçados mas podem ser engraçado se
nós compararmos um peido o é igual a um
mundial
os mais silenciosos são os mais
perigosos bônus contra a comparação na
conta comparação nos pegamos um conceito
e fazemos uma comparação inversa ao
conceito um ano passado um jovem revelou
um cabrito é um sabe que em moçambique
disse que o cabrito como onde está
amarrado mas em 2008 o cabrito foi
colhido onde estava mais nada
a base da piada está mesmo na surpresa
surpreendam que temos está a ouvir
sempre será engraçado eu gosto de vir eu
amo trânsito
quando eu rio
naqueles dez primeiros minutos que a
piada invadir o meu cérebro tudo
desaparece desaparece mundo desaparecem
as preocupações desaparecem as
necessidades
eu próprio aparelho a própria piada que
não fez vir nos aparece só fico eu em
plena harmonia com eu mesmo em paz e
feliz satisfeito é a harmonia paz
felicidade a mania é tudo que nós
precisamos pra lhe darmos com a vida de
forma positiva e pessoas positivas
transmitem positividade a todos a sua
volta só expositivas tem melhor jornal
somente só expositivas promovem melhor
de ambiente de trabalho e ambientes
sociais e todos nós sabemos pelo
deputado mendes à corrupção mais saúde e
é isso que eu vim nos transmitir aqueles
que eu gostaria de nos transmitir aqui
positividade
eu gostaria que vocês também transmite
sem possibilidade das pessoas
a vossa volta trilhão
[Aplausos]